Travis is with us in Atlanta Georgia
hi Travis how are you I'm doing fine how
are you better than I deserve sir what's
up well um
I've just recently started listening to
your show on XM and you kind of take the
wind out of me and I got your book and
I'm reading it and my question is I'm in
chapter six and it says before you get
started yet to be current with all your
creditors and right now I'm robbing
Peter to pay Paul I mean it's tough I'm
you know I'm up to my eyeballs and I was
just want to know what's the first thing
how do I break that cycle like how do I
dig my way out don't you okay my screen
says you're recovering from bankruptcy
are you in a BK yeah I uh about four
years ago I I had a big problem with
addiction and I filed chapter 7
bankruptcy and luckily my wife didn't
leave me she stayed with me and we have
three kids and cuz I just want to take
the second chance to you know rebuild my
life and then I didn't just but it's
tough to bounce back yeah so you been
dry three years oh yeah yeah they don't
man she she she left me on New Year's
and that was my rock bottom yeah that'll
do it so what were you addicted to
pharmaceuticals prescription pain pills
okay good for you man that's a tough one
to break and it's a lifelong battle but
I appreciate that yeah I'm proud of you
so what is your income of about 55 okay
and how much debt have you got oh around
sixty okay all together on what well I
owe 30,000 to family members and I have
some small loans and about 18,000 on my
car mm-hmm are you paying anything on
the family members right now at all uh
no okay
so out of the 50,000 there's not you
know half of it you're not paying
anything on right now well it's tough my
everyday bills and it's now loans and
stuff like how much is your house
payment uh 550 okay that's not a lot
good okay
Iran Iran that's fine all right more
than anything what you guys need is a
detailed plan and you and your wife
working together to stick to that plan
okay because when I start going down the
list of things with your household
income you said you make would you say
55 or 60 55 you make $55,000 okay I know
you got enough to pay food I know you
got enough to pay lights and water I
know you got enough to pay your rent and
I know you got enough to pay the car
payment yes sir
and and I know you're wasting some money
because everybody does especially
somebody thinks weeks ago I that would
be completely irresponsible yeah that's
just no no that's just normal
that's okay and this is the last thing
to clean up in your in your process of
healing that you're going through so
it's great I mean we're just sweeping
out the corners here together brother
it's all good you're gonna get there
you're gonna get there so a written plan
we're going to put you on a thing called
every dollar which is an app for your
phone or your computer
you and your wife together and you're
going to start tracking every dollar
before it leaves because if we just took
a yellow pad right now and we wrote down
your payments and we wrote down your
income at the top and then you'd look at
the difference you'd be going worse the
risk that money going absolutely that's
what I'm talking about you're gonna when
you get organized the way I'm gonna
teach you to you're gonna feel like you
got a raise okay and the other thing is
this one of the things that we work with
a lot of folks that are coming back from
addiction and some that are even in it
one of the things you rebuild with your
spouse is trust yeah yeah and Trust is
rebuilt on the money side and
communication is increased on the money
side
than just about any other area so this
is going to be a great tool for healing
your marriage you to learning to work
together to fight this debt monster
together and there's going to be a lot
of communication about where the money's
going y'all are gonna be talking about
it you're gonna be making the decisions
together it's going to increase
communication and Trust in your marriage
so it's going to have some effects on
your life that are going to be awesome
that hadn't really got anything to do
with money and it's a natural part of
where it right where you are it's this
is a perfect time for you so here's what
we're going to do we have a one-year
membership to a thing called Financial
Peace University it includes
connectivity to your bank for this every
dollar app on budgeting which is about
$100 thing it includes any of the videos
of two or three of our classes are all
in there it includes community in there
and here's the most important part
there's nine lessons that are taught at
a local church near you
a bunch of local churches near you in
Atlanta you pick one and you go to those
nine lessons as well on how to handle
money one of those is how to do a budget
one of those is how to get out of debt
one of those is how to work with your
spouse about money and yours you and
your spouse are going to go to those and
I'm gonna pay for all of it it's free oh
man okay so I'm gonna be part of your
healing I want to be part of your story
because you're a hero you're winning and
I won't be part of that I like being
around heroes so and then when you when
you're you know winning at this area and
you're working with one of the guys over
to 12-step area or something and you see
one of these guys who's right where you
are and you're two years ahead of him
you'll know what to do you can put him
and you can pay for it put him into
financial peace you can do that you'll
pay it forward then okay yep you'll be
able to help somebody else once you're
not broken more agreed absolutely all
right you can do this man
and I'm right here I'm not going
anywhere so if you need some help as you
go along you call me again okay yes sir
how old are you 27
love it you got the worm oh I think kids
you know I'll be able to bounce back so
that that building trust my wife is a
huge thing yeah yeah you're bouncing
back you're the kind of guy that does
that
you can do it you got this I'm proud of
you well done hold on Kelly's gonna pick
up and she's gonna get you signed up and
get you into all those classes and all
that's membership and everything and
show you how to do everything and we got
this for you we're gonna walk with you I
want to be part of this story I like
being part of stories when people are
winning open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money you see there's something we know
about addicts we work with them for 30
years 100% of them have money problems
you don't get out of it because it's it
whatever it is that's eating you on the
inside that you're that you're hooked
into it's gonna take all your money
eventually it might not right off the
bat but if you're gambling at it you're
a porn addict your prescription drug
addict your cocaine or alcohol a hundred
percent of you end up broke until you
get eeling for the addiction 100% nobody
makes it out so you gotta feed it the
Travis is beating it y'all pray for him
this is the Dave Ramsey show